Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for waking up early and joining us today for our 45th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Is it loud today?
Loud?
It sounds different!
That's weird.
This is us for today, okay?
Can you hear us, Ruffians?
It's a bit loud.
Loud puppies.
This is us for today!
BAU BAU!
Well, for Ruffians joining us for the very first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday.
A.k.a.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
That means you can hear us write.
Can you hear us?
I aim to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Loud and clear.
We didn't change anything, but... This is how it is today!
It's just a bit louder FUWAMOCO Morning.
Moco-chan!
We had another Pero Sighting!
How are things going?
Maybe we're okay without him.
Maybe it's okay.
BAU BAU!
Let's not worry too much.
Let's not worry about stuff, okay?
On happier news, have you heard, Ruffians?
Did you hear?
Do you know?
Right now hololive has an official shop for a limited time in Tokyo Station!
You know what that means?
You can get your merch now whenever you want if you're in Japan!
You can touch the merch and look at it until your heart's content before deciding to welcome it into your home, you know it!
The shop opened the other day on the 16th, and it will be there until January 18th.
It's located in the basement floor of Tokyo Station, and it's part of the Tokyo Character Street.
I'm not.
You can also find our senpai and Tokyo Tourism Ambassador Nekocchi-senpai, Calli-senpai, and Gura-senpai greeting you there with new goodies too!
And of course as well as our other senpai you know much from other hololive members too!
Advent, you know, we're still just newbies, so you won't be able to find us there this time.
But we're on the screen, okay?
We look forward to when we're included there too.
Please go and take a look if you're in Japan!
BAU BAU!
But, that's not all.
If you're not able to find us at Tokyo Station, this weekend!
There's definitely one place you'll be able to find us, and that place is... New York City!
BAU BAU!
Yes, we'll be making an appearance as guests at Anime New York City this weekend.
I'll be holding a panel together with all of Advent on Saturday.
And we really can't wait to see all the Adventrix will be there.
Right!
We just finished the rehearsal for it and we're very very excited.
We'll also be making appearances at the hololive booth and the exhibitors hall throughout the weekend.
And today, Shiori, Bijou, and Nerissa will be making an appearance there at 3pm EST.
So please don't miss them, okay?
We'll also be holding a Rock n' Rawr Party Mini!
And a Q&A session there this weekend too!
We wanted to be able to make the most of this opportunity, so that's why we're doing two different appearances as well.
We're really happy, but Ruffians, we're really excited to be able to see and to hear you cheering for us!
But, for the Q&A, please remember, okay?
Demon guard dogs are really good at remembering faces.
Got it.
So think carefully before you ask any silly questions, okay Ruffians?
Not that you know that.
It's not a threat.
Because Ruffians are so well behaved.
Yeah, it's not a threat.
Got it!
BAU BAU!
But that's not it!
Advent will also have some very special merch on sale at Anime NYC too!
A special t-shirt and a folding fan!
You know, it could come in handy, especially if you're looking to make friends with other Ruffians and ventrix!
And you know, it also makes it easier to spot in the crowd these other t-shirts, like you know, the Halloween t-shirt too!
BAU BAU!
So much excitement!
Ruffians!
But... You know... Excitement... It sorta stops there.
Why?
It's Friday.
There's another misunderstanding.
Cuz you know it.
Ruffians!
I have something to say.
It's not a confession or anything, but I feel like you might be misunderstanding something.
You're not misunderstanding anything, right?
I'm just being silly, right?
No.
You realize that Fuwawa and I, we're twins, right?
Identical twins.
And you know what identical means?
It means the same!
Yeah.
Not fraternal.
Got that.
No.
I see a lot of Ruffians saying that Fuwawa is bigger than I. What do you mean?
You have eyes!
You watched their debut, right?
Right!
You looked at our official profiles, right?
You should know the proper info by now.
It's been more than a hundred days, okay?
You know, we're the exact same height, okay?
Got it.
We're both 155 centimeters.
5 feet, 1 inches, 155 centimeters.
The only big difference is our eye color and our ears and tails.
I guess they're a bit different.
But we're identical!
So, why do I keep on seeing you say weird things like that?
Hi!
D-d-different weight?
You got it.
Because if you think otherwise, you need to check your facts, okay?
Got it.
I don't want to see anything weird from now on.
No misunderstandings.
Use your brain, okay?
Yeah!
Got it.
No misunderstandings.
How could they think that we're not twins?
That we're not...
What?
What are you saying?
Why are you gonna make the misunderstanding worse?
BAU BAU!
Got it.
BAU BAU.
Well, Ruffians.
We sure that...
I wonder why.
Good news!
We're able to go memory card hunting with Mama Puppy the day afterwards.
Not only did we just get one PS1 memory card, but we actually got two of them and an extra PS2 memory card too!
BAU BAU!
And you know, an even better news!
We kept the PS2 running, so we just shoved the PS1 memory card in!
And then we phoned Meiling, and guess what?
She let us save!
No issues!
She even congratulated us.
Very kind.
So we're happy!
From now, nothing will get in the way of our MGS journey!
Let's continue on our mission as Solid Snake O'K!
BAU BAU!
I'm excited.
All's good that ends... It's not ended!
It continues.
All's good.
All's good!
Yes!
All is good!
BAU BAU!
Hello fans.
We have some happiness, but... How are you doing?
How are you doing?
Are you doing good?
You know, yesterday was our first full day when we weren't live anywhere.
What did you think, Moco-chan?
It was... sort of weird.
But!
We did get a lot of homework done.
Yeah, we did!
But... There's still more to get done.
At the very least, Mayuri-chan shouldn't have any more tears.
For now.
There's still a lot of things that we need to get done and done pretty quickly!
Yeah!
You know, the end of the year is quickly approaching and everything, so... That's us.
That's us.
Happy!
Homework!
Done!
But... Yeah... You know... If we want to be able to get some of the things...
We gotta hurry up our paws a little bit!
Otherwise, you know, FUWAMOCO will be kind of...
Disappointed.
Grumpy.
Yes!
You know, so we need to hurry up!
But you know, we did get one good sleep and a walk in Florence, so that's helpful.
BAU BAU!
We'll continue working hard, okay?
We'll do our best, okay, Ruffians?
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
We went on a walkie-talkie.
We realized something.
Ruffians, has it maybe gotten a little bit chillier where you are?
Maybe just a bit.
A bit cold?
Well, in the Northwest Passage, it now is completely feeling like winter outside.
In other words, it's now the season of FUWAMOCO!
You need your fluffy, fluffy, your fluffy clothing, your fuzzy clothing to keep you warm, okay?
Are you ready?
Do you have your FUWAMOCO pajamas to keep you cozy at night?
Your FUWAMOCO scarf?
FUWAMOCO gloves?
Please make sure you stay warm out in the elements so that you stay healthy, okay?
It's because FUWAMOCO is like fluffy.
Fluffy and fuzzy.
Fluffy and fuzzy, right.
FUWAMOCO keeps you warm.
It's FUWAMOCO pajamas in Japanese.
Yeah!
But you know, as FUWAMOCO, FUWAMOCO is FUWAMOCO and we're pretty fluffy and fuzzy, but we're still making sure to bundle up too when we go for walks, so... You don't forget, okay?
No forgetting!
Okay, got it!
It's cold.
BAU BAU!
1, 2, or... Doggie of the Day!
It's the time of the day!
What do we have for today?
We have... The Dead Taco!
Taco!
It's a Doggie of the Day!
Very cute!
Oh, and he really likes a good kitty.
I love the moo-moo nose.
Except in cats, even though the cat doesn't like it.
Sounds familiar.
You can barely see, but Tako has a very good hold on that kitty too.
Yeah, that's exactly how you do it.
Taco's such a cutie.
This is a heartwarming picture too.
A big heartwarming picture.
It gives us energy.
But how does Taco BAU BAU?
You know, maybe like when they're huffing cats?
BAU BAU!
Something like that.
Shiori!
No, this is Tako, not Shiori!
Tako has a moo-moo nose.
Shiori does not have a moo-moo nose.
Sometimes we call her a cow, but she doesn't have a moo-moo nose.
But, ah, ah, Tako, I don't know.
We're not teaching about Tako's name since we've never had a Tako before, but if Tako are as good as Tako is cute, then I think I like them.
But we can tell that from the wonderful smile Tako has, you know?
BAU BAU!
And next we have... Today I went for a walk!
Where did this Ruffian go?
Let's see... De-den!
Such a pink skirt!
It's fluffy and fuzzy too!
Right?
But... I think it's fuzzy.
It's pink!
It's fuzzy!
It's... It's me!
Mococo!
Got it.
You went for a Mococo walk.
Okay.
Thank you for sharing your walk with us!
BAU BAU!
And for our Question of the Day, we have... De-den!
So far, you have only
Good question, huh?
Not even a Rock n' Rawr Party have we done a solo, right?
Well, I don't think there's really that deep of a reason or anything.
It's just, we enjoy singing on our own too, but we like how our voices harmonize and complement each other.
Right, yeah, but... You know, we're really happy, but we also really like you to cheer for us together as a unit too.
Right?
But... Maybe...
Just maybe... There might be something interesting coming up, but... Just maybe... Maybe.
Both are good.
Together are good.
Exactly!
Exactly.
Thank you, Ruffians.
We hope you're excited for everything.
Yeah!
I also want to say a big thank you for all your submissions today, Ruffians!
Please don't forget, don't ever forget, that FUWAMOCO Morning is a show we make together.
Together!
We need you here.
Your submissions to be able to make FUWAMOCO Morning the thing it is.
So thank you!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
And next, we have our next stream coming up.
Our next stream is... Only a few hours.
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
More information coming very soon!
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
We have much!
This weekend is Anime NYC!
But on Saturday, like always, we'll be holding our FUWAMOCO Rock n' Rawr Party!
And this time, yeah, we're doing another hololive only thing!
Yeah!
We're gonna be singing our senpai songs!
So we hope that you'll be there.
We'll do our best to...
Properly pay respect.
Just a bit nervous.
But we'll do it the FUWAMOCO way, right?
FUWAMOCO version.
Have lots of fun.
Please join us, okay Ruffians?
Let's have fun, okay?
Wow, now the week's coming to a close, but the weekend's just getting started!
It's just around the corner, okay!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
And for joining us this entire week, too!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Momo!
BAU BAU!
Victor Castillo!
Me!
BAU BAU!
Decorative Cake.
MP509.
BAU BAU!
Tencho.
Hawkmoon.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!